I really want to start with the most
important thing and it's an individual
question for you Matthew uh do you think
it was your performance as Thornton and
cocaine bear that has led to uh the box
office Juggernaut that it is I've told
many people this I I tell my partner on
a daily basis that it was mine it was my
eight seconds on cocaine bear that led
to the Juggernaut that that disrobed
Ant-Man I really want to see cocaine
bear I'm pretty excited about it you
definitely should see cocaine bear it is
a blast and see it with a very crowded
theater yes
um jumping into why I get why I get to
talk to you guys uh I watched this whole
series I was blown away
um I can't recommend it enough I'm so
impressed with what Scott did uh for
each of you uh can you talk a little bit
about why you wanted to be part of
something like this
um and how much did you actually know
about the characters or how much was it
just oh Scott Burns is making a series
yeah I'm going to do that I think you
know a number of things you just said
were were definitely a reason as to as
to why I don't want to speak for Heather
but yes a number of us I think Geno
jumped on we we both have been fortunate
to know Scott for many years know what
is close to his heart and and the
projects He likes to make uh and and
really he's he's a unique and rare
burden that he can do these incredibly
entertaining projects that have these
incredible uh messages behind them
um and it you know it is an enormous
message that I certainly wanted to get
on board with
um and like I said at the same time it
can uh a fantastic piece of
entertainment yeah I think Scott and his
work he wants to he's a social activist
he wants to make the world a better
place I think he's making this show so
that we all care more about global
warming and do something to change it
before it's too late and I think that
attracted a lot of actors including me
just to feel like you want to do
something good with your art you want to
entertain people and also it's
educational and if fun way hopefully and
disturbing yes have you guys actually
seen have you seen the whole series yet
I have only seen our episode I I want to
see the whole series I can't wait I have
enough now I'll be watching I probably
won't be watching our episode sadly I'll
watch your Clips he doesn't like to
watch his own words I never watch it but
yes I'll look forward to you know
watching all the other episodes I'm not
sure how much you know about the rest of
the storyline but the uh the scale and
scope of what he accomplishes in this is
jaw dropping in terms of the realistic
portrayal of the future
um can you sort of talk about uh like
his writing or the team's writing
because it wasn't just him but but what
they're able to accomplish with this
series yes you know I they were I think
it was a shrewd piece of Storytelling in
that if you take a timeline of that
scale and scope you you have the
opportunity to present to a large
audience what it is we're all looking at
because you know the as as many
scientific facts that we're you know hit
over the head if if it's not presented
in a visceral or kind of personal human
way then sometimes it it will never
connect and I think it was it was
incredibly it was incredibly clever them
to to you know to present this this
story of what this what these
catastrophes know you know we're looking
towards uh in a way that's you know we
we get to see in real time what is
potentially possible talk a little bit
about filming your specific episode for
soon to be fans of the series is there
anything that they would be surprised to
learn about the actual making of the
show every episode was shot in New York
even though the show takes place on all
these different continents and in the
Arctic you know all these places it was
we tried really hard to be
environmentally conscious we didn't use
any single-use plastic we we you know
tried to to practice what we were
preaching
I think yeah I think we're very
successful it was it was uh it was a
great undertaking you know as a as a
pioneering project for for an industry
that
at times isn't the most environmentally
friendly so it was you know even even in
that small step it was an incredibly
positive you know outcome Matthew I'm
curious what did you when did you find
out what was your character's Arc uh and
what was your reaction to that arc when
I when I was told that how you know the
what the character rock is I was I I was
bullied by the fact that you know
ultimately there's there's an element
where Nature Nature has its revenge to a
degree for both of you I like talking to
actors about the way they like to get
ready for like a big scene or the way
they like to work so I'm just curious
for both of you if you're filming
something like emotional or dramatic or
something that you know is going to take
a little bit out of you on say a Monday
how early on are you actually prepping
for a scene like that are you doing
anything special over the weekend or are
you at the point in your career where
you sort of have it I mean I like to
create a whole back story and just like
what was my childhood like and what was
the thing and how how do I know this
person what are all our little memories
I create all these memories which is
really fun so I probably do way too much
preparation
I was I was fortunate and my character
was just incredibly angry so with three
kids in the house I came to set prepped
and ready to go oh my God that's so
funny I'm just thinking about that uh I
definitely want to know Matt uh if you
don't mind um I'm also looking forward
to Perry Mason a huge fan of that series
I wanted to know if you could tease
anything about season two oh gosh that's
uh that's a question
um no it has more twists than a packet
of Twizzlers it's uh it certainly you
know undid me in a number of times and
and what I'm glad about is that it
completely 180s from I think what you're
expecting from the end of season one is
to the what happens in season two I
think it's very unexpected which I was
very happy about getting back into the
show one of the things that I think is
so fascinating is how something like
this hopefully will actually impact real
world discussions on the climate because
sometimes I think it's so hard to talk
about
um in the future up in some of the
future episodes people are wearing
oxygen masks and walking around with
tanks and it's just something that might
actually be in our future can you sort
of talk about how really good art like
this can really hopefully lead to better
conversations well Scott you know a rope
contagion which I think a lot of us
watched during the pandemic and I think
people were kind of Blown Away by the
amount of accuracy that he predicted
what would happen I think he does
exhaustive scientific research and I
think he he's done the same with this so
yeah that is kind of terrifying well
most of what was certainly terrifying
was a lot of those things you've
referenced about you know people wearing
masks and tanks and you know coming out
at night because you know temperatures
are so hot we're all
based on the scientific research that
was presented to him during this so and
he would say well
that's nice John that's not you know
something of my imagination that's
that's actually based on what scientists
are thinking might happen so
Food For Thought yeah it's um I have to
wrap but I think that sometimes people
need to actually see it rather than be
told it yeah it's more visceral to watch
people and care about characters or hate
characters or relate to characters and
just reading some dry scientific facts
exactly Scott's point so long may
continue thank you so much for being
part of a great series and giving me
your time have a really great day thank
you nice mandalorians